it's started here we go crown stars
three zero seven five six starting in 20
and change or at less than twenty anyhow
well it's a round robin this is not
warzone land these are three minute time
control and actually it's there is no
handicap so both sides I'll actually be
starting with the full tree so here we
go I was just ready to double the points
okay quick thinking now quick thinking
what's unprotected this guy so that
means this guy is unprotected any others
any others any others any others this
guy both night puns the Knights and the
corners are stupid okay after all that
what do I do
come on this one this seems like a good
start yes the bishop could come out the
rook is playing I am oh wait okay wait a
second
this Knight probably wants to come out
okay two minutes twenty eight oh are you
kidding me but capture away from the
center just so my bishop could play he
wants to play that Bishop where does my
knight wanna be
let's do this Oh what did I do to my
bishop he's stupid now
stupid bishop I wanted to play my knight
here but I didn't want to obstruct my
rooks view of the c4 pawn this diagonal
is opened up a little scary let's defend
this this pond is gonna be unprotected
oh okay I got a strike at that my
opponent doesn't have a dark square
bishop support it like this okay my
bishop is dead what a dead duck right
there
what a stupid piece on b1 tal Pilar tal
pawns Queen here so my knight could get
to this square something because he's
stupid - what is he doing I could Castle
as soon as I move my bishop - f - like a
king side castle Oh was that a slipper
ooh ski it might have been here we go
just like that I'm castled and my knight
needs to do something else
the Bishop's gonna play there my Queens
gonna go to B - I want to weasel my
bishop around weasel it around actually
if I go here I'm gonna allow for this
even if the bishop plays here I'm gonna
look for the light squares bishop here
is you're gonna be enough time to
convert it the King what is he doing I
was trying to get where okay my knight
needs to help next my knight wants to
get right there my queen wants to get
back over to e2 I'm looking for h4 f 5
my my bishop wants to play also he's
gonna be playing soon and I should just
be pushing up here what's that night
doing I don't want a night trade I want
my knight to be on the f5 square and I
just want to push here so now right here
is gonna be a juicy juicy juicy square
right I'm gonna play on the other side
actually I like having my knight
somewhere I'll are my bishop right here
where it puts pressure on the knight and
facilitates this advance and I probably
should have done that first I'll do it
next let's get it in
if the b6 then I come over here my rook
was doing nothing
the D file was closed so I don't want to
cap okay now I'm more inclined to
capture if the night was there to
recapture then I would have some issues
so my rook is really well placed here
the knight might be looking for what
let's come back here watch over a base
point and let's do this I should have
done this a bit soon or taking into
account this night coming here okay that
we're just gonna have that capture
captured towards the center and now here
we got my rooks are doing something
their ups aren't doing anything and the
knight is actually trapped I should have
picked up on that a lot sooner actually
when that replayed there I think it was
close to being trapped
so I recaptured the Queen maintain
control and we have a rook check coming
up and this should be close to a beat
here take get the other rook doing
something let's give a check if the
Queen blocks it leads to me and what
else my bishop needs to start playing
Bishop wasn't doing anything I want to
get to the 7th actually let's get right
here pick off the c5 pawn push my C pawn
away and do this is there gonna be a
perpetual check or something
just take here if the Queen leaves
there's probably mates and stuff no no
no oh right here bishop have this square
row to be eight okay check and then get
my queen over here to defend against
like queen age six stuff let's just do
this I'm okay with the Queen trade okay
now I have this and then G four and then
everything is locked up thirty one
seconds of twenty seconds okay Queen
trade I could just let me get my King in
a better position right here there might
be a pawn push I have takes now it's in
a pin everything's falling now with
check it's gonna be it I got the rook
and just go quick here let me just guard
that rook and push these guys a lot of
time okay that's me back to tournament
let's see what's going on in the other
games okay all the other games are done
there's only three that go on here we go
I was ready to double the points again
so with this arrangement
what's unprotected that's my first
nothing okay my bishop doesn't have to
move in order to be developed I like
this as a start my rook when I Castle
Knight to f3 what do I want to do with
this guy let's come here first I don't
want to play here cuz what do I think
I'm gonna do it my bishop if I develop
my knight there so I probably want to
play here but if I play here my pawn I
don't want obstruct one of my center
pawns so maybe I want to play there I
have a plan I really do pawn push night
here upon c4 bishop c2 pawn to b3 and
everything is working let's give that a
try this is like a bird's opening so
although my queen is in the corner and
well there's a lot of other things that
are different about it but I want my
night here I want c4 and maybe I should
have done c4 before this e3 move so I'm
assuming that my opponent has they that
they won their first game
mmm let's see I could just kick this
night away right where is it gonna go
chase him away he's got no business
being there where does it go I have a
nice Center now and I'm really tempted
to just kick this night around a bit
more I'm doing it with the opening up of
this diagonal now if the night plays
here I have c4 and my bishop is sitting
the night gaining a lot of tempo on this
night I could actually hit it again and
can you believe it
it's really close to being trapped in
fact Bishop takes Knight as a necessity
in order to maintain material so I have
the bishop here at the very least now
the night plays there but I think I just
back up a single square a single step
and then h4 is threatened and the night
is running short on squares once again
so this is this Knight is having a it's
really getting a workout here my knight
can now play to b3 before I was saying I
didn't want to do that but that was when
the pawn was still on this B 2 square
and okay so the knight is prepared to
come back to this point I think I go
here pretty much automatically it's his
only square and well yeah soon enough I
think just h h4 g4 and probably just
queenside castle or maybe I should
reserve my option still I do have a
bishop check let me kick this night away
first and then play g4 my opponent needs
to be very cautious of well not only
time they're under a minute but also the
light squares and the bit the Queen is
now in a box here what does she do what
is this Knight - what is this rook do
okay let me take away some squares here
starting with this one and then they'll
get my see pun involved gaining another
gaining more control of a center square
this night could be pushed around again
and okay I have a tremendous space
advantage here that was a defendant
there's Queen here giving check picking
off this pawn the king is close to being
made it actually I'm just gonna give a
check and there they're way down on time
here so King here there's something like
h6 I think but something like Queen
takes pawn is available to just gonna
queenside castle and then there's very
little time now for team black can take
this there's no fantastic discovery of
text that the discovered attacks that
the night has could always give check
and if the rook blocks play to east
III to give another check alright I
don't know how many rounds this is let
me check real quick those games are over
with again round three how many rounds
how many rounds this is a a five rounder
so this is round three I don't know what
the standings are standings are okay I'm
tied with that guy - and - and I'm not
paired up with them okay what's up
protected let's see this one and this
one
so these Knight pawns again this is very
similar to a position that was already
played once in the king and queen Rd and
a good spot I like this I like this is a
start rook Bishop Queen are all helped
and the pond controls the center square
d4
okay and now it's gonna no no no let's
do this
and then whoa I didn't take that into
account that Queen I wasn't expecting
the Queen to recapture and I should have
just getting ready to grab here better
defend that dark squares ouch
okay so now space in oh man or this one
Fisher random resignation time no
compensation right how could there be
oh is this Knight gonna is there like a
self mate or something well I could
castle
my heart scan just skipped a beat I
thought is there gonna be a mate or
something no there's no me my king was
running short on squares a little bit
but now just occupy the center get all
my pieces working I'm up a full lady
here a lady develop my f7 grab this pawn
push here I'm gonna pin don't take so
there's nothing to do develop with the
Queen
Knight f7 coming up here we go this is a
killer check actually this is leading to
Maine I had that earlier I didn't even
see it
I wasn't looking I was getting caught up
in the routine of just development
although wait wait wait wait
host upon block did that would have been
bad I lost the Queen back oh that was a
bad pre-move okay let me close out what
other games are going on I want to
observe another game this guy I got to
do some home cookin okay what does he do
what does he play in um
is he a Sicilian player it's gonna come
down to me and this guy maybe oh come on
Oh black has white on the ropes what
happened the king the king is exposed
running for the hills
no oh man here we go get ready this is
gonna be a battle I think I'll be paired
up with oh wait no you know what I
everybody plays everybody that's what
this is I was thinking that it's the
whatever your score currently is in the
tournament you get paired up with
whoever has the same score I thought it
was a little weird that I didn't get
paired up with
this Stefanovich in the previous round
because we both had to and it looks like
black is well on their way is there a
better placement for these pieces excuse
me there's also a bishop check that
could be thrown in that I think would be
good fifty seconds for black less than
forty plenty of time there goes a rook
and it's okay white needs to start
chanting the defense chant chanting the
defense chant okay they're done and here
we go this is gonna be tough
I'm gonna get paired up oh it's gonna be
a last rounder against that guy these
bishops don't have to move what's
unprotected quickly quickly quickly this
one and this one is accessible so that
means this one is also let me play here
to start boom on move to and fissure
random a piece can be captured also on
move one there we go
boom on move one you can also castle in
fact right here with this arrangement I
could Castle if I really wanted to I'm
not going to do that though and I'm not
going to take the rook because he's not
going anywhere where does he think he's
going that rook has to stay put and it
still can't go anywhere and now my
bishop can see I'm watching over this
pawn I'm looking for d4 okay that's been
been prevented um what about my knight
my knight would love to get here it's
licking his chops you know what I'm
gonna take a positional approach to this
I'm not going to take the rook I want to
make sure the LightSquared Bishop is off
the board and I want to get to this
square I did grab a poem excuse me I did
grab this pawn so I'm content with that
and I want to focus on this square and
here we go get to this point right here
take into account this Knight move there
might be a bishop or a pawn move and
then this is a an issue
I don't want a castle let me do this
just preparing to meet like a pawn push
with f4 get this Knight here I should
have done that maybe a bit sooner okay
having this happen and then my queen
needs to come up Oh to drop the rook
opponents going pretty quick here what
do I do with my king it's a little bit
scary actually I should just break I
really need to just open up files for my
rooks and I should do that before I
castle if I Castle my queen is not
protected and after push and takes I
can't recapture I could place this rook
in a pin and now I am supporting this
advance I think I have enough on it
although the bishop could be grabbing
here oh that could be a bit annoying or
not I think capturing here first with
this pond was better oh this is a bit
scary mmm oh I think I play here which
looks a bit weird but I think it's okay
and now I'm getting out of this pin and
now I'm getting ready to take here and
beyond the night I can still Castle
kingside
pick up the King drop it on the rook and
they switch positions so let's see how
this pans out I think maybe this push
might be a good idea
efore okay now that let me do what let
me put pressure on this it stopped this
advance or actually it couldn't have
been played anyhow I think as soon as
I'm castled everything is gonna be okay
so take here there's gonna be rook there
whew that's really scary let me get this
Knight on it or no I shouldn't do that
let me castle could win this and this is
a this is pretty scary yeah this is
pretty scary right here
oh I should have done that and if ripped
there I had a fork or something
didn't I a deflection chased the night
away and then I could move without rook
takes G to one minute left 14 black um I
think pon takes pawn is good there it is
okay I need to get my rooks doing
something there's gonna be a pawn push
oh man oh man oh man oh man oh this is
very scary I was ready to play Queen
here no wait am I getting made it this
is really scary I'm on this point I'm
gonna give up my queen yes there's a
mate threat though over here
I want the Queen's off let the Queen's
come off check come on check check check
check check check
Queen trade no mate get the ladies off
this is still scary very very scary less
than 30 ticks 27 26 25 24 when you don't
have anything constructive to say my
trick is to just count the seconds no I
didn't want to do that
get the night grab a pawn push it run
pawn okay I got this pawn everything
should be alright you give a check look
out for the deadly check I got the
rookie got the rookie I got the bishop
run power and he's very fast as pawn is
very fast run no time no time no time no
time but wow did that get a bit scary
right there
back to tournament one more round this
is for the the crowds look at the prizes
they are big okay here we go last round
I hope there's a good arrangement here
what kind of arrangement are we going to
have here oh is this we're not gonna be
fired up well man is this not gonna get
fired up what's happening here it's not
like a war zone and there could be like
an error and then ah
man what's this what's the count so far
are we both the leaders oh no he the
African actually lost a game I don't
need to draw okay I only need to draw oh
it's very close to UM the same on the
kingside everything's protected here
this is unprotected Wow very very
similar you switch these two and these
two and it's a regular chess okay
Queen pawn opening or do we call that
still King pawn I think I'm gonna do the
same right here
establish a pawn in the center and night
out I don't know that that's a good move
um let's go night
let's go night pawn push I have to
support my Center if I take there's my
knight gets pushed around I think okay I
have an adjunct I'm four seconds five
six oh man I better hold my Center my
bishop could come out oh why don't I
make those sounds I don't know I don't
have answers to those questions
um Bishop g4 okay I had my queen around
to watch over this and now Bishop d6
could be played but both of my bishops
could come out right away
oh man heavy fire let me tell you all
right that night needs to go and and and
look I'm in a position actually
queenside castle now and I'll be
opposite the king be very scared white I
can also put pressure on this pawn if it
pushes but then there is support with c4
I think this is needed Oh Oh what do we
have
um okay I can actually capture that I
can also castle with check and then take
here the Knights in a pin oh I have a
leading development my knight could play
here
rook out here or something just take
that and then do what next Bishop here
Bishop here
Knight here I don't want this push
I wanted to play Bishop d6 but I thought
there could be that I just want to get
to this square I would love to get the
dark square Bishop is off the board
let me pile up on this Bishop there's
also this move Knight g2 and I want to
get the bishop off get the dark square
Bishop off and I think everything is
okay
I want to get to this square soon so
what's the time situation Queen exchange
coming up
or maybe just back my bishop up and
Bishop to f4 or f5 looking for
weaknesses let me back up Bishop f4 what
else
my opponent wouldn't fall for that would
they okay let's do this get the clean
off of these dark squares and then
pinpoint g2 oh wait a second what's
happening here oh man tricks Knight here
is a TKO move isn't it what am I missing
there gonna be a queen check I got me
and I'm on the Queen there might be
Queen here needed what's the scoop I
made on b2 look out be very scared oh
wait a second I missed that Oh
um I really tempted to just take here
and trade queens and then try and burn
time should I try that otherwise I moved
my knight and this pond is gonna be
gobbled up I gotta try it I gotta try it
come on time burners time burners time
burners time burners I think this is my
best practical chance time burners maybe
they'll snip this guy snip this pond
it's free it's free it's free it's free
ah
bishop check before guru skis were in
the air dark square weaknesses the
bishop and has it must be a pain here we
go
no time oh that one hurts time pressure
you see what happens in time pressure
let's go
clinch it looking for a clincher where
is the clincher resignation chopper rook
chopped upon but go after another pond
okay here we go push give a check just
make sure you're not dropping anything
god this this you have the bishop run
pawn okay Lu Big Five Crowns all right
cool a big 5 good games a 5 rounder
tournament not as exciting as the the
war zones that's for sure the rounds
have to wait and stuff so 5 William B I
played him in the first round he had a
good tournament for very good for four
wins in a row very nice